distal is an adjective it is a
descriptor for the ends the end the ends
of what the whole
object all right Next
Level oh god oh do I do I need to give
instructions
here oh no all right you ready the legs
will line long attached to the star I
[__] hate you great uh so star side
up no not up that's down because when
you turn the table the table is a
finished product the Stars would be down
because the legs attached to them so
that's down star side up lines down got
it oh boy I'm literally can't do
anything I'm just stuck in a room by
myself pie boys oh hey I got it wrong
Mark that was wrong the legs will linely
attach to the star that should be all
you need
I got it
now how do I get where am I where are we
I I oh we have different ones do we have
different ones you guys have to send me
the pieces nothing hey Mark you guys
have to use the teleporter to send me
pieces Mark I think you have to do I
don't who am I sending this to I see
you're sending it to me and I'm sending
it to W I need two legs yesterday I'm
trying here's a leg okay that's to the
wrong table but I'll take it all right
teleporter incoming I think how do I can
you can you push it I I pushed the
button Mark who whoa I got wieners
coming with I got wieners I got legs I
got legs with wieners all right I'm
sending no you just took it back sorry
sorry sorry sorry
sorry uh Mark the distal liy of thou
moon is green not in fact flower you
submitted something that was wrong so it
changed and you didn't let me read what
it was all right well I didn't have the
rest of my life to wait all right line
to the flower the line of the leg to the
flower that's I don't have a table
anymore well yeah Mark I need a tabletop
I think wait I got a bunch of stuff on
the teleporter for excellent teleport it
oh hey look I got a tabletop line to the
flower that should be all you need the
pointy flower or the curvy
flower what there's a flower on each
side one of them is pointy and one of
them is how do I have eight legs to the
wrong table teleport again Wade teleport
again oh God okay uh the line is dust
thou flower right
yes hey Mark I need those directions
again for no particular reason why were
you God okay line to the star the line
side of the leg is touching the star got
it easy I have a weer some more than
yeah I'm getting I'm getting
them
I there's one weer pending I'm going you
know hard is to to oh boy wait teleport
the weers if you need them uh I need a
little I need a little Ley I have one
little leggy on the teleporter if you
would just push the button it would come
over to where you are got it thanks
man done
he I got all right yeah we
got how that happened I have to be
honest ah look at that we got four
points for that one
table that was pretty Prett good thank
you thank you are you intentionally
reading my instructions wrong cuz I feel
I'm not reading anything do we need to
change who's doing the instructing I
think we beat that level Next Level all
right level nine we're ready all right
cool all right okay I'm I'm
down oh hey oh no we have to nut okay
you guys get you guys have the
nut what are we building okay you need
to put 10 rounded nuts in the Llama
what's a rounded nut all of these things
does it matter what color they are nope
just 10 of them need to go in the piñata
then turn it can we can we put more than
10 no exactly 10 10 is the number thou
sh well I mean is it is it possible to
put more than 10 cuz we might have okay
oh that was you guys can't count well
done all right nine shall be the number
of nut in 1 2 3
six 7
seven88 9
9 nice the number Thou shalt count to is
10 1 two three 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 nailed it
eight shall be the number one two three
three
four five
six seven seven eight
eight
yeah that reach 12 2 three four five 6
seven eight careful
nine 10 uh 11 11
12 12 did you put it in did it did it go
in are you sure uh
12 yeah good save nine one two three
three 4 5 6
78 N9
nine holy [__] how are we 12 12 12
one two three three four five 6 seven
eight nine 10 oh no 11 how many many I
got no I had it right there
a wait you really screwed that up at the
end you're welcome we had a good Rhythm
well you had like eight seconds I had to
help hey I got number one so you're
welcome three four four five four
five we really had it under control
smooth this level looks easy huh this
level looks
easy uhuh all right let's do it all
right
uh I'll get the little one I guess
okay oh what else is
around I don't see
anything no Direction back here go ahead
uh putting this in the
area oh
wait instructions here we go uh lines
away from the Star you got it baby like
if we think of this like positive
negative and then the line is the
negative side we could be like we could
call the the pointy part the negative
side I love this lamp then
it's yep yep you get it yeah I'm with
you I'm with you okay cool can someone
wiener me in the middle oh ah where did
it go right there
no my middle my middle weer my middle
here just Popp poing I need a wiener in
the middle where's the wieners we're
missing a wiener we're missing a wiener
it's it's right here it's in space a
little bit oh space wiener come back
there you
go rotate it rotate it put it on go go
yep there you go facing the wrong way
yep grab
it oh shut up [__] turn it that was my
bad no that's Notre you didn't even have
the light bulb in there there there you
go it's still not correct I know I know
I
know partial credit uh D Rod th Dilly
Lial you talking about
Li disposition I'll look I'll look
limited Dilly you didn't even see what
it was
I know we don't checkerboard Checker
board's on the exterior edges
checkerboard exterior yeah Mark we need
you to come screw all right you got it
don't worry what's the
rush I got it in there we go for the
love [__] you slow
[Laughter]
bastard sorry I got a little angry
there all right hurry your shake you
slow
bastard I love yelling that after the
time is
expired all right next
one what that oh no Mark how would you
describe these patterns oh God only one
way to find out oh look at the things
all right where's instructions here we
go oh Bob by the way each symbol has an
opposite side that's different oh
loop-de-loop okay which one no it's no
it's definitely this one yeah loopy loop
or loopy loop with a gap in it facing in
or out loopy loopy up Loop me up legs
short side long
side what the legs do they long or short
short Mark come do the screws wait let
me make sure oh guys that's loopy down
you guys are so it's not it's not a
attach Mark come help I know but I'm
just checking I'm just checking cuz you
were gu wait do the wait put do the
there no it's got to turn the leggy got
to turn that's short side what do you
mean my god oh wait I thought it could
go a different way you can wait get
something else God damn it sorry Jesus
see I I literally thought like the leg
the way it was like it could either the
short side of the leg attach or the long
side of the leg attach I didn't know
long of table no that's not the
place where do I go not over there see
I'm not it be over here where it where
do I go someone throw me throw me thr me
wait wait wait I'll throw it oh God okay
here here
here hey guys look was right God I told
you I told
you my instructions you want to read it
fine the the oh wow hey Mark which one
is the loopy same one loopy loop but
other way legs go on the loopy loop with
no dash in the middle
legs long or short legs on short side
legs on short side all
right
great what get out of my way
no move here we
go amazing okay someone thr come here
come here come here come here come here
catch catch catch catch incoming got it
all right why are we in such a heart
all right same orientation as the first
one loopy loops and the solid loopy loop
is the top okay legs on short side not
this way not this way I got to flip it
this way yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my Apple watch
keeps going off that I'm in a loud
environment the loud the loud thing is
me Apple watch I have bad
news this is Great's the last leg
where's the last leg sounds like a
question that you should have the go
here we go here we go all right all
right come
here catch catch
catch got it oh we're the best we're the
best we're the best we got like a
million points
probably like we weren't even
here that's pretty good A we were only
40 away from the aming
masing oh yeah no when you're right
you're
right Next Level oh no what's happening
what is this everything hey guys there's
a conveyor belt is that
good
instructions okay this is for the table
oh look a a thing you
can die on all right how do we do the
table table short side quad
loop
quad quad loop short
side quad loop is the top or the the is
that where the legs go I think we'll
just refer to it quad loop attaches to
the legs in that manner
okay I can't fit through here apparently
rotate lb
oh ah can someone come do the
screwing uh where's the gun it's right
there it's right there nope okay well
that's a b that's not the
gun I thought you needed the where'd it
go where it disappears when you get
close just hit just hit like X or
whatever okay uh there you go where's
the last is it did you bring the last
leg over yeah I thought so is it
underneath where you guys are standing
saw wait I thought I saw it it was just
here what what where the [__] did it
go um why what where'd he go nothing
where'd it
go where where' what H what happened oh
here it is we're
idiots hey
done hey we're getting really good at
this
guys what it's fine you guys you guys
all right
oh have you have you guys heard the new
Mario voice in Super Mario Wonder no
when he dies it literally sounds like a
quite a death Shak he
goes I don't know if that was like
uh oh well look from now on we'll only
discuss instructions as they attach the
instructions are
gone Mark what do you mean they're gone
they're
gone right well just put it on there Bob
we're going to guess all right it goes
like that all right need the other ones
right here found him found them okay
it's okay checkerboard attaches Outside
Inside I
just way do you want it
uh oh no uh yeah let's go get the new
pieces wi seems like a good idea Mark uh
help here I'll hold this and you attach
to this where inside yeah I threw it in
here I threw it in here somewhere wait
waade you touched it where' the drill go
right here here oh damn it okay
checkerboard inside oh hey how do you
tell did you staple that he did thr face
over here cuz he didn't say I can't tell
until he was already holding it in place
oh none of us could tell how could you
tell I assumed you did it right that's
how I could tell all right checker board
inside should probably confirm that it
didn't change right oh son of a [__] no
it's right we don't have time right it's
right it's right go go go 15
14 someone staple me okay our our things
are not the perfect perfect go go go top
stable St
stable oh no
God God damn
it oh
[__] I don't know why we thought this
game was going to be so difficult we got
to do it again we didn't get a star what
do you mean no we
don't oh okay I'm lying to you you're
wrong
stupid is it actually faster to skip
someone tells me it's not you mean to
dash yeah Skip it's very slightly faster
it's dashing skip you kind of Skip it's
called it's called dashing you go can't
skip than
you help help me help
me what is
happening Wade was suffering a hell of
his own Miss
no where's the where's where's the gun
do we have the gun yeah it's already
been thrown over here all right Mark's
doing the thing you're doing loopy L
long what loopy do long you know loopy
do long legs attached long on the loopy
side on the loopy side with no dash or
with a dash just it's a complete Loop
okay the other side is dead man's Loop
Mark you got to come drill
us actually I could well just just do it
I don't know oh it's under it's under
the table okay hold on okay is this
right I don't know I think so yeah it's
loopy long okay yeah it's Loy long you
got a real loopy long going on here
loopy long yeah loopy
long man no yes all right that Loop be
long uh where's the other one I'll go
look no but I'll look why you say me why
you say it so self-righteously like that
ah tessellation inside
checkerboard
outside there but the okay it's like a
tesselating pattern why is that
underground it's not attaching correctly
here let me hold to see how oh wait yes
no wait stop I doubt Mark rotate yours
rotate no l L1 rotate yours Mark I am I
am now Check Yes okay I'm going to do it
that's it that's it this is the way
oh why is that possible turn it in turn
it in it's good I
didn't there you
go why is that
possible I hate
everything that was perfect
everybody my bad here get the M you guys
okay
wa over here trying to kill me what do
you mean no no no I'm just I just
helping wait on this bridge his survival
Instinct
K what are you
doing hey waade how's it going I can't
see I got
tears uh all right you seen a Game of
Thrones where it's like the two seab
bound dudes on the bridge and one of
them's wobbly that's that's weade what
are the in what are the instructions I
thought the instruction I didn't see uh
oh wait yes I did checkerboard let me
check no rush man all right checkerboard
inside checkerboard inside drill me done
all right yeah that's good that's good
no no all right hold on hold on hold on
okay checkerboard needs to go inside
like this x yes
no wait why why top no hold on there yes
top top go go just put it in yes we did
it I did it we did it I did
it oh man hey we got a star hey look at
that we're the best well Wade's the best
oh look how many rooms there is look
this is this is relaxing we just calm
down here a little bit what oh no oh
sweet
Jesus so oh Jesus give me figured this
out but this is cushions and patterns
there's different cushion shapes and
there's different patterns of the
cushions I think this and the patterns
have different colors that could still
be correct I'm going to need you guys to
trust me on this one because this is
exactly what I was here for why are you
laughing why are you
laughing this is what I was this is what
I was oh God I don't like I don't like
that okay all right rocking chair cool
that's fine what shape of cushion who
hey what's up rocking chair thing all
right so you're building a rocking chair
that much should be obvious got
it
okay
oh
oh ah all right good news both cushions
are the wave pattern there we go we got
two rocking chair legs all right so
you're going to put the rocking chair
middle what shape is the cushion is it a
thick you're going to go for you're
going to rounded edges rectangular wave
pattern are we missing a thing how what
you got to bridge him with the bridge
that bridge that in the back see that
you put it in the
back which one's the back
back yeah yes wait
yes what are you doing what put it the
thing do I do that that that yeah that's
it there yeah right like that yeah
uh-huh the other leg goes on it like
that nope n why why is this why is this
why do I hold let me hold it some other
way I I hold it hold on I don't oh no
rotate El elbow for the RO T that just
doesn't make any sense why would fail
failure nope why would
hold this I just it keeps F why are you
saying my name I don't know how it's
your fault but it clearly seems to be
your fault what do you mean it's not
what is happening there there there
there there no no wait what did we do
did we do it
wrong wait wait can you set it while
it's on the ground
wa nope no nope nope nope nope nope nope
I think there might might be something
wrong with this Mark I've got to be
honest no uh-huh done nope no you got to
hold it got hold it still for a sec Bud
okay stop moving wa why are you moving
we got this
oh oh wait this was supposed to go on
the a that's what we did wrong that
plank was supposed to go on the top this
was supposed to go so what you're saying
is I should just attach this all
together yeah yeah put it in there no I
can't I can't attach anything else to it
okay well that's fine oh okay can you
wait could you just wait wait I need a
moment I can't even turn this in I don't
understand what this I'm out let's hey
let's just restart the level let's why
don't we just do that yeah let's do that
that's we got this I'm going to go look
at the instructions all right you look
at them this fine we all right we're
making a rocking chair yeah that's what
I put the legs on the put the Rockers on
the bottom of the frames like before the
plank goes in the center
holes and the rectangle should be
aligned long ways forward and backward
on the on the top of the seat part
yes and then there's a crossmember the
little rectangle that's on one side of
that needs to go forward towards where
the person sits I think that's right
that's right right there right yeah that
yeah let Sticky Side is up for the the
thingy we see staple where's St oh yeah
got it baby all right okay here's this
I'm going to try and get the I'm going
to try and get the correct cushions here
oh I pressed the wrong button I'm sorry
about
that stop moving it stop throwing it why
are you throwing it I think we need to
get the back on first right stop pushing
me I have this lined up
so there we no yes right if only we had
the back on got it all
right stable it stable it stable it
stable St it stable it stable it stable
it stable
it why oh hey I pressed the wrong button
okay stable it
nice all right Bob are you just Bob what
are you I I'm trying to I'm trying to
get the correct um cushion set up go
nice all right we got this oh wait oh
wait I think I might be close I think I
might be close let me check let me check
we've done our part mark thank you the
bottom is the big tall wavy and the back
is the tight wavy I did
it if you you can you can kind of like
you know travel
around hey guess what I think that's
wrong oh no no no no way Jesus Christ
okay still money again boys money still
money it's a rocking chair same dealio
fellas exactly the same dealio hard
corners and sure yeah rounded Corners I
know what I'm doing never mind uh Mark
you staple
me that don't oh and that there uh-huh
right there right there wow I really
hate cushion really getting in the way
of things there we
go the same they're both the Third Kind
the the Triangular
wavies hang on
done they're both the Triangular on
you okay like that and then
also waitting on you like that do it do
it do it do it do it do it that might
actually be correct all right I don't
know if I
wanted oh my
God I figured out the cushion we have
time for another one I in the sky why
are you on top of me I am in the sky
oh God I I'm number one I end you are I
end on that we do a podcast all right
don't say another word about it yeah
just go listen to the podcast if you
don't know what it is but you can look
at this too late Banner that's
appearing I don't know about that on my
end yeah make Dana do it I don't do
it I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna
go